well held the secretary steve barclay is
due to make a statement in the house of
commons shortly and he has rejected
claims the government wasn't prepared
for the heat wave
well we have well established
contingency plans in place following the
heat wave in paris in 2003
across the nhs extreme heat plans have
been published each may the last one
just a couple of months ago so local
trusts manage the pressures themselves
we're coordinating that
across the ambulances additional
resources have been put in place to
surge more capacity to call handlers to
support
over the weekend and into this week and
we're closely monitoring the situation
and cabra was an opportunity to look at
those pressures across the system just
as we did at the weekend are you start
what impacts are you starting to see
today or can you get any can you observe
any sort of tangible impact so far of
this heat wave today as the temperatures
pretty personal
well we're seeing a increase in calls
and the extra resource we put in place
is to manage that but there's also a
time lag in the data because the highest
point of the expected heat wave is
actually going to be tomorrow afternoon
so that's the point of maximum concern
but we're seeing an increase in calls
that's why we put more call handlers in
place it's why we put additional funding
in an extra 150 million for the
ambulance service a further 50 million
for 111 and indeed other supports such
as 30 million pounds for auxiliary
ambulances so extra resource has been
put in place the contingency plans that
are well established have been activated
and we're meeting uh regularly with nhs
leaders with ambulance chief execs to
closely monitor the impacts and
particularly the handover
times
so we can mitigate those with the
increased pressure they're facing what's
the latest advice in terms of going out
because you can see people
almost beach i was looking at earlier
people are on the beach people are
swimming should they be doing that
should they be staying here well i think
it's about common sense following the
the advice a public health advice from
the uk hsa
in terms of hydration a cover
covering up being in the shade avoiding
the times of the day when the heat is at
its peak there's a particular message
particularly for
for teenagers children some of those who
may be tempted to go for a swim
there's significant dangers of that
quite often when people go swimming in
rivers
when we have very hot weather so so it's
following common sense steps uh keeping
an eye on neighbours and those who are
vulnerable and following the guidance
that's been put out by the relevant
bodies what about schools are you
picking up any evidence of schools not
opening today what's the latest advice
from your from your point of view and
what's the latest situation in terms of
pupils being able to go to school well
it's important we get the balance right
with schools that uh some stay open for
key workers not least in the nhs so it's
important that schools do continue to be
open but at the same time head teachers
are empowered to make local decisions as
fits the needs of their local schools so
the department for education has put out
guidance to head teachers on the
practical steps that can be taken by
schools obviously it is a local decision
for them to take but at the same time we
need to get the balance right in terms
of making sure that for key workers
there is education continues to be on
offer in order that nhs staff in
particular can continue to get to work
kit multiples has also been sharing
these cobra meetings we've seen the pm
having a party yesterday at farnborough
air show today we've obviously got this
big internal party leadership contest
going on are you confident that the
government
is on top of this and is able to deliver
on these big priorities for the public
and deal with this heat wave and
seriousness of it given all of the other
political things that are going around
and the accusation that we've been
hearing from the opposition that the
prime minister has checked out well the
prime minister is engaged i i had a
phone call with him on saturday uh to
update him specifically on the measures
we were taking in terms of ambulances i
had further meetings with ambulance
chief execs and others over the course
of the weekend so the prime minister is
engaged on this but at the same time
it's quite normal for the chancellor
director of lancaster parlor the role of
the covenant office is to coordinate
cobra across government that's exactly
the role i was doing when i was uh in
the cabinet office and it's quite right
that the current minister for cabin
office coordinates across government
that's why we had a discussion this
afternoon we also had a cobra over the
weekend
and meetings in the week and finally
we've seen a pretty vicious leadership
battle are you confident that the party
and the government can come back
together after this or are some of the
divisions that have been laid bare going
to be too deep for people to really
start to get on together and get on with
the business of government after the new
prime minister is in place well i think
it's hugely healthy for the party that
we have such a strong field of
candidates for members of
parliament and then they the membership
to choose from so i think we've got an
extremely strong field of candidates the
party will unite behind the new prime
minister and it's good that we have a
full and vigorous debate on the issues
in terms of putting those questions to
mps and the party membership